1 2 3
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
j'étais ramener un maillot mais le quart
sont des cubes de francine on arrêtera
cocorico tu vois ici
eh ben on écoute on est sur ta pmp et
mokhtar il est passé il a pris le chien
lui remet la combinaison complète de
l'équipe de france après quoi il rentre
dedans lui la plus forte tu as a way bon
ça va lui faire inscrire pour un amour
franchement tu es en amont
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais bon
et adil tu as une force incroyable non
mais c'est vrai adil c'est un gars il va
n'importe qui au bras de fer c'est non
pas ou alors tu y crois que tu peux
battre motards ont pas assez de leurs
modèles
moi je n'ai plus mes bgc bocar tu crois
que tu bats tu leur as tu une balade en
toi tu te bats mokhtar adil qui va
sauver la vie cet été mais j'étais je
suis allée chez le coiffeur et sur la
tête de ma mère j'avais chaud il fait un
bail qu'on a ici tout raser ici pas rasé
et she rendez vous avec lui et je vois
dans sa tête
l'on voit et il veut pas me le dire tout
de suite parce qu'il m'aime bien donc il
fait comme s est jouée pendant vers
d'une minute
ils ne parlent pas et après il se met un
petit peu à 3 mètres comme ça il me
regarde de loin comme ça et là il m'a
dit triaud c'est une catastrophe
tu as peu plus tu vas passer un été
d'enfer et il m'a ébahi l'a fait venir
un mec exprès à 2 200 km non dans 250
kilomètres pour me rattraper le délire
c'est bon bah ouais merci d'ailleurs le
parcours en un public masculin et
féminin
[Rires]
regardez le statut là bas au fond ça tu
tombe mal c'est mon père allait à neutre
[Applaudissements]
deux cas cela fait combien de kilos me
du fait qu'on a alors attention comme
acte comme un tuyau 135i l'on rêve sa
thèse il reste alors ils se connaissent
attention attention les gars attention
celui qui casse son procès
2 3
ça s'est mal passé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]